of course it wasn't the only time Daniel
had to deal with the complexities and
physical rigors of filming in water heck
the guy seemed to be underwater a lot of
the time especially for a movie about
Wizards flying through the air right in
the halfblood prince he and Michael
Gambon AKA Dumbledore have to fight
against Undead corpses known as INF
faery the battle is in a dark
water-filled cave and apparently the
process was not ideal for Daniel in an
interview in 2022 he reminisced on the
shoot saying they had him hold onto a
wire while he was holding his breath
underwater then when they called action
he was yanked quite hard out of the
water of course since the surface of the
cave water was supposed to be on fire at
the same time he had to ascend into that
said Daniel quote so I flew out of the
water and there was like a ring of fire
around me so I was just like bursting
out of the surface of the water through
a ring of fire sounds like fun